[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster or the Liz truss
era started properly today the first
cabinet meeting the first prime
minister's questions and behind the
scenes putting the final touches to a
crucial package of measures on energy
that is going to be announced tomorrow
and it could Define her whole friendship
premiership right from the very start
now the big debate is how to pay for it
against a backdrop of spiraling debt and
a falling pound trophonomics is about to
be put to the test so plenty for us to
get stuck into as we bring you tanks
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
there's nothing new about a Tory prime
minister who when asked who pays
says it's you the working people of
Britain well the new prime minister
perhaps unsurprisingly disagreed with
that
well there's nothing new about a labor
leader who is calling for more tax
rights
Battleground in the coming days and
weeks is clear it's all about the
economy your taxes and how to spend them
and of course there's never been a more
important time to break away from the
bubble in this cost of living crisis and
speak to our viewers panel here they are
hello everyone looking forward to
speaking to you guys a little bit later
on the show we'll also have some top
guests for you including the former
Northern Ireland and environment
secretary Teresa Villas Labor's Shadow
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds the
man that some have called Liz truss's
favorite Economist Jared Lyons and we
are also going to be talking to the
conservative MP Alicia Cairns lots more
besides coming up on the take
[Applause]
thank you
good evening well there is now a very
clear choice between the two main
parties on the big issue of the day how
to pay for an energy plan likely to top
150 billion pounds well labor wants
windfall taxes on oil and gas producers
Liz truss has ruled it out and that of
course could mean a lot more borrowing
but the markets are nerdy and the pound
is now at its lowest level against the
dollar since 1985 all the way back to
when a certain hero of the new PM was in
charge won Margaret Thatcher well we'll
find out the energy details tomorrow but
already it's been a history making week
like you've noticed that Liz truss is
elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
it's fulfilled its function and I will
now be gently re-entering the atmosphere
and splashing down invisibly in some
remote and obscure corner of the Pacific
now it can be confirmed that it has
officially happened list trust is now
officially prime minister of the United
Kingdom we will transform Britain into
an aspiration Nation with high paying
jobs Safe Streets and where everyone
everywhere has the opportunities they
deserve I will take action this week to
deal with energy bills I've just
realized my alarm is going off on my
phone oh my goodness what is the alarm
it's getting a bit of Dr Dre it's just
an eight o'clock alarm it is 9 A.M and
we are live in Downing Street where
members of list trust's new cabinet are
currently meeting for the first time in
number 10.
foreign
prime minister who when asked who pays
says it's you the working people of
Britain
well there's nothing new about a labor
leader who is calling for more tax
rights
well they're Dr Dre maybe I think was
the standout one for me but of course
Energy prices and how to pay for the
package of measures we'll get tomorrow
absolutely dominating at a political
debate at a minute including our prime
minister's questions there was a fairly
heated exchange between the new prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition and interventions from the
backbenchers too like this one
a pub restaurant in my constituency in
Barnet got in touch with me to say they
were struggling to find an energy
supplier and the quotes they had got
hold of show that they would be paying a
600 percent increase in their bill to
320 000 pounds they can't survive that
will she ensure her plan to tackle the
energy price crisis helps businesses in
the hospitality sector which our
communities value so much
well my right honorable friend is
absolutely right the hospitality
industry is vital and I will make sure
in our energy plan that will help
support businesses and people with the
immediate price crisis as well as making
sure there are long-term supplies
available will help businesses as well
as helping individual households
well the person who asked that question
was the conservative MP Theresa Villas I
spoke to her earlier started by asking
why she chose that question in
particular
because I feel that
the cost of living crisis and energy
price Rises are just on everyone's minds
and I received an email from a popular
pub restaurant in my constituency just
giving me these frankly terrifying
figures about what they were going to be
asked to pay for their energy so I
wanted to focus on the fact that
businesses are finding it tough as well
as households yeah I remember speaking
to a pub owner actually on Sunday and
just been completely shocked actually
frankly by the kind of increases that
they were going to be seeing and what
did you make of the prime minister's
response well I mean I I welcome the
very clear response that the package
that will be announced tomorrow will
include help for businesses as well as
households I mean obviously we don't
know what that is yet but it was really
reassuring because of course much of the
debate is understandably about
individuals and families but we don't
want to see sort of Mass business
closures as well so we do need to focus
on the energy costs that their face two
it's gonna be expensive though isn't it
um Liz truss has ruled out a windfall
tax do you think that was the right
thing to do
well the
we already have a windfall tax at the
moment so
um it's already the case that the the
big energy producers are contributing to
solving this problem and and we have a
progressive tax system so higher earners
and companies will all be playing their
part in in funding all of this so I I
don't think it was an unreasonable
decision for for Liz to say that she
wasn't going to introduce a specific new
windfall tax but I I feel it's best to
wait for the detail in the package to
see how it will operate and how it will
be funded in detail yeah we are of
course all weighting that aren't we and
tomorrow's announcement and but at the
same time if she's not going to go for
her tax Rises then it looks likely it's
going to be funding by a pretty big
increase in borrowing I spoke to Philip
Hammond the former Chancery of the
weekend and he said that he's worried
the conservative's reputation for fiscal
responsibility and competent governments
at stake do you think that's right
this is this will have an impact on
borrowing in the public finances and so
there are risks I mean that that was
obviously the debate during the
leadership election but this is an
emergency I mean we we haven't seen sort
of an energy price shock on this scale
since the 1970s you know we we are
seeing Vladimir Putin using energy
prices as a weapon of war and in times
of emergency unfortunately the public
finances are impacted and they're simply
no way to avoid that if we're going to
do what we have to do but I'm I'm I feel
confident that our new prime minister
will be looking very carefully at all
the numbers to try and minimize the
damage on the public finances and to
ensure that we can get them back on a
sound footing in the future well I guess
one uh way to get it back onto the sound
fitting would be through taxes though
something that she said that she doesn't
want to put up well she she's clearly
ruled out
um that she she's very clear about the
tax reductions that she want to make so
I I would suspect there's there's no
sort of flexibility on that but as I say
you know I'm sure she and her whole new
team will be looking carefully about how
this is funded uh you I'm just
interested to know as well you know Liz
truss uh new prime minister you know if
this week of course you know she's been
pointing her new cabinet and she's had
her first promises questions today what
kind of prime minister do you think
she's going to be
I think she's going to be determined
resilient
and she's got real kind of grit and she
she is absolutely determined to deliver
so I I very much believe and hope that
she's going to be able to do that she
faces this is incredibly difficult
circumstances not just energy price
Rises not just the war in Ukraine but
the aftershocks have covered on the NHS
as well but I think she performed really
strongly at Prime Minister's questions
and she's got a long and impressive trap
record in government of getting things
done so that's what I I think she's
going to do as prime minister you sat
around the cabinet table with her what
what's what's she like
she is she's very engaging she's got a
good sense of humor and the years we sat
in cabinet together
um for much of the time she was doing
the defra brief and I remember her
staunchly standing up for the um the
food and drink industry is one of our
most important sectors so she's she's
always been a very impressive figure in
government and in Parliament you of
course didn't back her in the leadership
race you went for Richie sunac
um I have to say you know looking at the
cabinet appointments it's pretty clear
that she's rewarded those people who
were loyal to her like admittedly there
are some Richie sooner backers when you
go further down the rungs of the
ministerial ladders when it comes to the
big decision makers she hasn't really
made a most inclusive cabinet actually
she she's appointed some incredibly able
people to her cabinet and her government
you know we're we're a parliamentary
party with with a great many very
talented and capable people and I think
it's understandable that
um Liz wants some of her key allies in
the big positions and as you say you
know she's appointed some Rishi backers
and indeed she's appointed people who
directly stood against her as candidates
in the leadership elections so in a way
the people that she relied on for their
votes I think so but I I think she's got
she has got a great team and that that
includes conservative MPS from from all
wings of the party and I I sincerely
wish them well you know it is it just as
we've been discussing they face an
incredibly difficult task as difficult
as any government that's taken office in
decades
Teresa Villa is there well it was pretty
clear from today's pmqs that labor wants
a clear dividing line between itself and
the government over how to pay for this
very expensive new freeze on Energy
prices well we're joined Now by The
Shadow business secretary Jonathan
Reynolds thank you very much for being
with us so what do you want to see
tomorrow from this trust well I do think
and we have had it trailed and there'll
be something to match Labor's offer to
freeze bills I mean we've been quite
clear people cannot pay a household
Energy bill of four or five thousand
pounds now there are mixed messages and
different stories coming out from
government but uh what we would like to
see is the existing package of resources
the government's put there much with a
windfall tax I mean it's legitimate and
fair to take some of that unprecedented
profit for the benefit of the nation as
a whole we'd also have benefited from
lower inflation put that together and
that's how we would fund a six-month
freeze in Energy prices and have support
for business as well that's what we want
to see now there are we don't know what
the package will be and clearly if it is
as one version of the story is that
households will will bear all the cost
of that but over a longer period of time
I think that is unfair and that's a drag
on the economy the government will have
to consider and if it's borrowing well
look what we've heard so far from
quasi-quartile is trust is that they
believe they can cut taxes increase
spending and somehow that will pay for
itself I mean that is that's clearly
untrue and we know it's untrue from
previous actions of former conservative
governments it's interesting isn't it
because you obviously want to see part
of it funded through taxation and you're
talking there about you know Liz truss's
plan just not making sense but I guess
what they would argue is that the way to
growth is through lower taxes that's
what she wants to see isn't it and I
guess if you're talking about the you
know the record she would also like I
suppose that now is the time to try
something different to do something new
to not go through the same tax and spend
can you see the argument I know that's
their argument but this is where the
Battleground is going to be so first of
all
um industrous has been a member of every
government over the last 12 years she
Bears some responsibility for that I
think it is interesting that their own
analysis is that that has been a failure
I mean they're very clear on that I know
Crossing quartet is called that treasury
Orthodoxy and for most people that's
conservative Orthodoxy so we both have
the same analysis you know things
haven't been as they should be now for
us
the problem is fundamentally it's a lack
of growth lack of productivity in the
British economy low business investment
is a part of that we know from what
George Osborne tried that cutting the
headline rate of corporation tax did not
increase business investment we already
tried that we know it to be true which
is Sonic to be fair to him made this
case and was correct in doing so what we
would say is that lack of growth comes
from lack of policy lack of free
consistency no industrial strategy or
it's been tried twice and dropped twice
and that's the wrong message to send to
business we don't spend enough on
science in this country our research and
development is it's a much smaller
proportion of GDP than any other
developed Nation these are the things to
look at and this belief that there's a
magic wand of cutting corporation tax
and you can pay for that as the
chancellor suggested on Monday by what
they call supply side reforms that will
make the economy grow I'm afraid that
it's conservative code for cutting
employment rights and Environmental
Protections it has failed and it's wrong
we'll find out won't we I guess you know
whose argument is right in the months
ahead certainly and this trust also
wants to look at energy at Supply in the
future of energy too and we're expecting
her of course to be looking at things
like more exploration in the North Sea
at Reuters reporting this evening that
she is poised to announce more drilling
licenses in the North Sea dozens
apparently more licenses for uh
exploration in the North Sea
is that a good thing in your view well
we'll have to see the detail because any
transition plan for the UK has always
had gas as part of that at the same time
I understand like you want to see the
detail but but we know that this is the
road of travel travel that this is what
they want to go down she said it before
she wants to see more exploration in the
North Sea is that something that you
would support well she'll have to prove
that it's consistent with our climate
change objectives internationally agreed
treaties that we have signed up to
she'll also have to do it how do you do
that though because we have a committee
on climate change that has a carbon
budget you're either in favor of
operation then we'll see or not well
it's a part of the transition if what we
don't know is is this new drilling for
already found oil fields gas fields or
is it new exploration that the time
scales of that will determine that
there's also a suggestion of well I mean
I'm skeptical that that can be done on a
time scale consistent with the Net Zero
transition and if it's if it goes it
gets so just to be clear if it goes
against the Net Zero targets then you
would be against exploration because not
only is that a breach of our commitments
by not sticking to our commitments we
raise the risk the cost of capital for
the kind of Investments we need in
onshore Wind offshore wind solar new
nuclear a hydrogen industry you know we
lose the jobs of the future as well as
breaching things that we've signed up
for and if it's a return to fracking as
we've heard part of it look the best
case scenario for fracking even if
people wanted it and it's clear they
don't with something like four billion
cubic meters in four or five years time
that is in no way going to compensate
for the loss of Russian Supply to Europe
and quite frankly I don't think even our
geology and environmental standards in
this country that could be done in a way
so it's the wrong answer and some people
would some people would say look uh we
understand of course the how important
the commitment to Net Zero is we
understand the need for investment in
Renewables but in a time of energy
Supply crisis don't we need to look at
every option on the table including in
the North Sea including [ __ ] you can
build a wind farm quicker than you can
get fossil fuels out of the North scene
we'll be doing both of those things well
it depends if she can prove that is
consistent with our Net Zero objectives
but if she can't not only is that the
wrong thing to do it will risk the
Investments that we most need to see for
the long-term future of the country and
I think again you know there's an
element of of to be honest fantasy about
a lot of Liz Christmas plans whether
it's on the economy and tax and spend or
on areas like this now we need the
detail to be fair to them but in terms
of what I've seen in the conservative
leadership contest I think we should be
worried there does seem uh one of the
few things that there is a concern to
say there is the need to try and enact
to at least freeze or reduce people's
bills in the short term
we also have a crisis in energy Supply
is there a risk that by acting to reduce
bills or to keep bills lower than they
would be otherwise we're not
incentivizing people to cut their usage
at a time when it's energy Supply that
is the issue I mean are you worried
about blackouts do we need to look about
rationing I I I'm not worried by that
because first of all when people say
freezing prices at the current levels
there's no incentive to reduce your own
consumption well let's be clear that
we're freezing them at levels
considerably higher so you know the
incentive is certainly there for people
in my constituency and I think the
nation as a whole if the government
makes the right decisions there
shouldn't be the risk of what you are
saying but let's be clear there hasn't
been there's a huge drop-off in in home
insulation installations after 2010
David Cameron cut the green crop that
that you know reduced the ambition of
their own policy you could have taken 15
you know roughly out of the demand in
terms of natural gas had those decisions
not been made the Bannon onshore wind
has been counterproductive and closing
the storage facility and you know again
another conservative decision really
poor decisions that have increased our
exposure but the government can still
make better decisions now and that's
what they need to do alongside measures
should we be looking at things like
they're looking at in Germany like
stopping lighting public monuments or
asking shops to shut their doors well I
think there is a there is some benefit
in a public education campaign around
you know different ways to reduce
consumption an amazing number of homes
in this country you don't even have
thermostats and that could relatively
easily be solved but I would worry by
talking about that that we are only the
government can make the kind of
intervention that is required on a
crisis of this scale and there's always
benefiting us all living our lives in a
more efficient way and using you know
scarce resources as best as possible
that's not an answer to the crisis this
requires real action from government
because that's the scale of the
challenge okay interesting so thank you
very much Jonathan Reynolds there well
we are as we're just saying as to
waiting for the details of the energy
announcement tomorrow so let's talk to
someone who perhaps knows more than most
what is going on behind the scenes and
actually political editor Sam coach Sam
can you share any light on what to
expect I think at the heart of the
announcement Liz truss will give
personally tomorrow will be a commitment
that she will ensure that energy price
bills are not going to rise
substantially from where they are at the
moment now where they are at the moment
is of course pretty much double for a
lot of people where they were just a
year ago nevertheless preventing them
going up from about 1 950 pounds a year
for the average household up in the new
year to something like 5 000 pounds
which is what some people suggest will
be a very big and important step because
frankly most people can't afford that
and there would be tens of millions of
households falling into poverty so
that's the centerpiece of what we expect
now it's going to be paid for by
borrowing that's the big political
difference that exists with labor who
say that a lot of energy companies
should be paying for it themselves from
the excess profits that they've been
making because Energy prices are high
but this package tomorrow isn't isn't
all about just insulating people from
rising bills Liz truss is going to say
that you can only offer short-term help
and we're talking about maybe a couple
of winters in the first instance if you
reform the energy market and what she's
going to do is promise all sorts of
things you were raising some of them
just there with Johnny Reynolds now that
includes potentially more drilling
licenses in the North Sea more gas
storage maybe sourcing out some of the
finances around nuclear power plants to
make the case that you can basically uh
introduce in the next few years a lot
more domestic energy supplies you don't
have to rely on the fluctuating price of
the International Energy markets now the
problem with that is that that's going
to take a long time before you see any
real benefit from it and until that
point you're potentially on the hook for
hundreds of billions of pounds if the
pressure from Russia on Energy prices
continues as it is so it is a gamble you
might think that conservatives are
uncomfortable with massive intervention
causing huge amounts of borrowing at the
moment they're sanguine because they
know it's so important for the public
this is a gamble worth taking it does
feel like a defining moment doesn't it
for Liz trust Sam thank you very much
for the explanation
you are watching the take we're live
here in Westminster up next we are going
to be taking a closer look at the new
prime minister's economic approach and
trying to add up some of those expensive
tax and spending pledges that she's made
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
I'm in the man Rasheed and I'm Skies
north of England correspondent telling
stories from this culturally Rich region
I call home
if the Taliban found your family what
would happen I think they're just going
to straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was on the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch when people
are disappointed you can feel the hate
I've always tried to put people at the
heart of the story like hearing from
young women who've been spiked via
injections I just felt physically said
that's really in my system
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless we give a
voice to communities often unheard and
unserved from a region with a distinct
history and Global impact
[Music]
support communities to grow food in Lost
and unloved spaces across the city so
our main kind of driving force is to get
people growing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Ivan Borneo I'm a sailor I spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
[Music]
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
hello welcome back we are live in
Westminster and you are watching the
take now there's a big shift in economic
thinking as the new PM takes over in
Downing Street Liz truss wants lower
taxes and supply-side reforms to cut
regulation so far so if that's right but
with huge spending on keeping energy
bills down and pledges to boost defense
spending as well she's likely to need a
massive increase in borrowing all as
markets get a bit jittery while Jared
Lyons has been called her favorite
Economist and can perhaps help us
understand her thinking he joins us now
I can see you smile though when I said
that you're her favorite did you see
that as a compliment or how do you how
does that go down on that one okay well
I think economic policies are sound so I
would say that as a positive is there
much is there much that you disagree
with her on then or do you think is it
the direction of travel that you do well
lots of people are talking about trust
economics but trust economics has yet to
really be defined so it's both what she
says and also what she does but I think
what's really encouraging is that she
wants to really address head-on the
immediate challenge is the biggest risk
we currently face in addition to high
inflation is the risk of a deep
recession and the two things that she
has highlighted that she will address in
the next few weeks the energy crisis and
also reversing the tax increases are the
two single most important issues to not
just ease people's worries about the
future but they're the two most
important issues to prevent that deep
recession global economy slowing might
be difficult to prevent a Slowdown but
she's taking full action in my view or
will do to address that risk so you
don't think that a recession is
inevitable a recession's not inevitable
look the two big issues as I say the
energy crisis by capping prices she will
take the risk away from people and from
firms the government will take on the
risk so that's an important factor also
it will cap inflation and internal
inflation expectations and then in terms
of the taxes clearly if we went ahead
with the plan tax increases it's
inevitable that we would have a
recession so coming back to your
question a recession is not inevitable
but the world economy is slowing and
indeed the markets are reflecting that
as well and you're talking there about
the need to act on Energy prices but
also at the need to try and keep taxes
lower as a not raise the law that surely
means we're going to see an awfully big
increase in borrowing
the biggest threat to the public
finances is if the economy has a deep
recession so that's what Liz truss is
confronting straight on so therefore we
should be reassured about public
finances and in terms of that the
borrowing if we look at the borrowing
figures the markets I think will be
reassured by measures on the energy
front that removes the worry about
growth collapsing I think the markets
will be reassured by Liz truss or indeed
quasi quite am the chancellor today
reaffirming what was already clear that
the bank of England remains independent
but more importantly coming back to your
question her fiscal measures are
necessary given the reasons I mentioned
to prevent a downturn they're affordable
and they're non-inflationary
non-inflationary because of the nature
of our inflation shock our inflation
shock has been triggered by supply side
factors exacerbated by poor monetary
policy not everyone agrees with that
lady some some people do say that
cutting taxes or or
canceling proposed rise in taxes would
be inflationary the ifs for example
sample and you know Paul Johnson now is
not the time for big tax cuts which
could themselves make inflation worse
okay right in terms of first the energy
price cap two weeks ago Goldman Sachs
said that inflation would hit 22
yesterday Barclays said based on fixing
the price inflation would Peak at 10 so
that's a big difference also bear in
mind that the obr the independent obr
said that one percent said this back in
March one percent off inflation saves
five to six billion pounds a year in the
full fiscal year so that's very
important in terms of the actual
inflation expectations component what we
need to watch is what happens on
monetary policy not just fiscal policy a
clear consequence of what Liz truss is
planning is that monetary policy will be
focused on Curbing inflation and fiscal
policy will be very much focused on
stabilizing the economy and tax cuts are
not the opposite end of the same seesaw
as interest rate hikes basically if
taxes go down down that does not mean
that interest rates go up but interest
rates will have to go up as the markets
have been saying and indeed the markets
were saying this way before Liz trust
looked like she would become Prime
Minister just want to talk to you a bit
about the markets because it feels like
you know there is a risk that you were
saying that you think the markets will
be you know reassured by some of the
policies that you don't think that
higher borrowing will lead to alarm but
at the same time it does feel like that
is perhaps a bit of a gamble I just want
to have a look at what's happening with
the pound as well because this is
another part of the story as well uh I
think I have to go do it this way there
we go this is the pound falling uh I
mean goes back as you say and it's not
just a trust thing it's gone back like
way back to 1964 this this graph but it
does just show how low the pound okay do
you realize what the main story was in
Tokyo this morning the weakness of the
Japanese Yen 30-year low the Euro
recently is an all-time low the key
story here is the dollar it's very
interesting one because the last time
the dollar was this strong was August 85
and then what we had was some something
called the Louvre Accord stabilization
amongst all the big countries to
stabilize it what's more interesting for
the UK is what's happening to guilt
yields and that's an indication of
borrowing now guilty odds here of tenure
guilt yields are around three percent
they actually improve today the guilt
markets so that gives you an indication
that the rate at which the UK government
borrows yesterday also hit a 10-year
High The Guild yields yeah and also like
this is not just this we understand that
the dollar is is strong at the minute
but this is about more than just the
strength oh god well let's get back to
borrowing rates because UK government
borrowers at a cheaper rate than the US
government also the maturity of our debt
is twice as long as the maturity of
German government debt so that puts us
in a very good position also bear in
mind that as I said if the inflation
Outlook improves that improves the
borrowing figures as well what comes
back to this is that the markets want to
have confidence about the policy no one
should ever be complained about markets
I've been in markets for 30 years but
it's about explaining clearly what you
want to do so coming back to your
question on the energy crisis markets I
think will be reassured on that front
making the bank of England really take
stock of inflation is reassuring but
then the markets I think will take
comfort from a fiscal policy that's not
just going to stabilize the economy but
it's quite clear that debt to GDP which
is lower in the UK than the other G7
countries is on the clear down a trend
so it's fiscal discipline fiscal
Financial solvency but the Market's
clearly like anyone they'll have to see
what is actually unveiled and that's the
key thing it's pretty clear that you are
happy excited even to see as some of Liz
truss's policies
um she said that she wants to set up a
panel of economic advisors to help steer
her policy are you going to be on it
well she said that the weekend I don't
know obviously is up to the Prime
Minister who's on it but the key to say
yes if you if you picked up the phone to
you well it depends on the terms of
course but the answer is probably yes
but the important thing about who who's
on it is obviously important but we need
to confront treasury Orthodoxy since
2008 Trend growth in the UK has been
very low the treasury says
growth is low more the budget deficit is
structural a decade ago they wrongly
used that economic thinking to justify
austerity which was wrong and in the
last two years they used the same
economic thinking to justify tax
increases what Liz truss is saying let's
not be in a hole and dig deeper let's
actually ask why we can't get strong
growth let's get stronger growth higher
wages and sustain what is pretty good
jobs picture at the moment so let's see
what she does I do think it's a sea
change in thinking and as we've seen
today she's quite she believes in it I
think the markets actually will give her
a voter confidence if she does deliver
on what she has said well we'll find out
won't we in a month ahead thank you so
much for being on the program out there
Jared Lyons now former Prime Ministers
always say it is one of if not the most
nerve-wracking part of the job being
grilled by opposition leaders and MPS in
the House of Commons it was Liz truss's
first outing at primus's questions
here's what our political correspondent
Joe Pike made of her debut
the anger the disdain and the contempt
we saw between Boris Johnson and Kia
starmer has disappeared after months of
parliamentary jousts about truthfulness
standards and fitness for office today
Liz truss and kyostarma parried each
other on policy the new PM arrived
cheers from colleagues even though most
of them didn't vote for her Rishi sunak
and his most high profile supporters
were nowhere to be seen
instead Liz truss was flanked by her
closest cabinet allies not a white man
among them Rising energy bills is the
issue of the Autumn and today a new
dividing line was drawn over how to pay
for it the government want to borrow
billions whilst labor prefer taxing the
profits of oil and gas companies
protecting oil and gas profits and
forcing working people to pay the bill
she's the fourth Tory prime minister in
six years the face at the top may change
but the story Remains the Same
and can't she see there's nothing new
about a Tory prime minister who when
asked who pays
says it's you the working people of
Britain well there's nothing new about a
labor leader who is calling for more tax
writers
same old tax and spend what I'm about is
about reducing taxes getting our economy
growing getting investment getting new
jobs for people right across the country
and it is not just the tone that has
changed but the language too our
analysis of Liz truss's answers features
the words energy and the economy a lot
as well as tax tax also popped up a lot
in Kia stalma's questioning as well as
excess profits and working people when
Boris Johnson was PM Theresa May used to
shoot spiky questions at him she seems
far fonder of her second successor can I
ask my right honorable friend why does
she think it is and all three female
prime ministers have been conservative
it's quite extraordinary isn't it that
there doesn't seem to be uh the ability
in the labor party to find a a female
leader indeed a leader who doesn't come
from North London
[Applause]
but opposition MPS seemed Keen to toxify
his trust as fast as possible the Prime
Minister may have changed Mr Speaker but
it's the same old being shouted down by
the attorneys you're going to be as
useless and corrupt as her predecessor
people in pontyprid will never forget
that she played a key role in a
government that failed Millions Liz
trust did do pretty well today but it
will be more tricky to repeat that
performance if her big interventions on
the economy and energy bills do not work
now sources suggest the labor leaders
team wanted to prevent him falling into
the same trap that some say Rishi soon
act slipped into during leadership
debates a man sliding at Liz truss and
after today's session secure
congratulated the PM on her debut they
will be head to head again tomorrow when
Liz truss announces her long-awaited and
much needed support package on Rising
energy bills
or we've heard and seen plenty from
Westminster today let's break out of the
bubble shall we and find out what the
most important people you at home our
viewers made of it all uh so far it's
time to speak to our regular panel uh
here they all are good to see you all uh
lovely to see you after the summer break
uh back hard at work we've got people
from across the UK and across the
political Spectrum as well but I want to
start off with the cost of living it
feels to me like it's the most you know
important time to really be focusing on
what this means to everyone and I know
that some of you have got some stories
that you've been sharing with the team
and I just want to talk to Andrew first
there's Andrew Farley you describe
yourself as a Centrist you're in North
Yorkshire and but on Energy prices you
work for a food packaging company I
think I'm right in saying covered
critical during the pandemic and you
were saying that the government's
talking about gas rationing for your
industry just explain to us what's
happening
so essentially aside from the price
freeze that the government were talking
about on energy bills
the the UK rely on a cold Winter's day
um where there may not be much wind
um we rely on EU gas for about 12 to 20
on a daily basis so if the EU haven't
got that gas on a cold Winter's day when
kilton's already threatening or has
turned off uh the the main pipeline then
we won't have enough gas on a cold
Windows there when there's no wind and
so it's it's almost inevitable that gas
rationing will occur in the UK for
industry not for the public for industry
and just talk to us a little bit about
the business that you work for and what
what is it that you do and do you use
quite a lot of gas then
yeah we do yeah um so I'm sort of part
of my my role as to responsible for
energy contracts so um it's been
obviously a very uh challenging period
um the the volatility and energy so it's
just a daily sort of um
struggle trying to to figure out uh how
to to map out the path ahead
um and and now hopefully the government
they're going to step in and lower uh
businesses uh energy bills for the
foreseeable future which will be you
know a Lifeline for for many businesses
across the country you know we've heard
all the stories and ours is no different
so it's it's really important that's
really interesting government
announcement tomorrow really interesting
to think about the business angle to
this too you know we talked a lot by
consumers but businesses at really
important too and also schools which is
why I want to talk to you next at is our
is our a better charger you are a remain
voter you're in London and but you're
also uh the chair or not the chair so
you're on the your Governor that's right
aren't you in a local uh primary school
and I guess for schools uh the the bills
that are coming when it comes to energy
must really be pretty frightening
yeah so so I'm more like School Finance
link Governor so I'm in charge of
helping make sure the school's got a a
budget that's healthy and it means that
we can afford to provide the best
education for our kids and if you think
about March of last year that's actually
when we got the first big hike in Energy
prices and it was a more than doubling
of our Energy prices then schools don't
face the same energy price cap as
households face and so right now we're
looking at wholesale like Energy prices
and they're very high even if they're
frozen at this level and we are we're
about to get our next quote in the next
month or so and we're going to see the
real cost of that and and to be honest
80 of my budget is is salaries for staff
and there aren't that many places that
you can cart and so when you see like
rapidly increasing Energy prices it's a
pretty scary situation in the school and
we obviously don't want to make cuts
that impact the education of the kids at
all so it's it's pretty tough yeah I
guess
um are you worried that what we're going
to see not necessarily your school but
certainly around the country positions
like teaching assistance going
yeah I think our school is actually like
particularly well placed just because
we've managed to fill our reception role
which for the area that we're in is
actually very uncommon and so if you see
the the enrollment numbers go down if
you also see the star salary increases
which I think are great for the staff
but come with no additional funding for
the schools and then you see these
energy price hikes I I'm a little bit
scared you'll see yeah for example
teaching staff who might who might have
to kind of be cut back on or even
support staff and I think all of that
could well impact the the position of
the education will provide really
worrying and of course it's the personal
as well isn't it and people's personal
bills Hannah Walker let's go to you at
next year are you all talking to us from
uh Dorset and your electricity cost has
nearly doubled hasn't it
yes it has and um I I've um got some
disabilities which means I we I use a
lot of um both electricity and water and
also I live in a place where I only have
um LPG gas so my income because I'm
retired is uh is fixed mostly I can't
really increase my pension and I'm now
getting my state pension
um so I have no way of making up making
any more money to pay for the increased
costs
um and I think that probably applies to
it to a great many people and
particularly those who are who are most
vulnerable
really concerning stuff and well let's
talk shall we about the new prime
minister now it's been really good to
hear some of your experiences some of
your stories so thank you for sharing
them we can go to Roy and actually Roy
Roy or you're a concern to support
yourself what do you make of Liz trust
so far are you happy with what you've
seen
um yes I've been pleasantly surprised
actually
um uh she did very well today and I was
um heartened by the cabinet choices I
must admit so I'm quite pleased with
um the positions that she's filled with
who she filled them
oh well let's go to our other uh
conservative supporter shall we uh Dr
Paul Blom who was a conservative you're
speaking to us from uh London
uh I've just been told in my ear that we
actually have to go to Hannah next not
entirely sure why but Hannah uh sorry
Paul I'm going to come back to you in
one second but we are going to get
Hannah's LeapFrog due in the order uh
Hannah what do you make of Liz truss so
far
ah well I'm I'm a labor Vader so I don't
quite see her in the same light as
perhaps some of the conservatives here
do
um I don't particularly like her choices
of um in the cabinet perhaps because I
think she perhaps could have gone for
Unity uh cabinet invited some of
Richie's student act supporters that
might have been better more inclusive
um I thought her acceptance speaks when
she won the leadership was a little bit
wooden and stilted to be honestly but a
prime minister's question she appeared a
bit more in control she was okay but I
think we just have to wait and see I
how it goes forward
um
wait she doesn't particularly impress me
it's more of the same really okay well
let's go to Paul now uh shall we Paul
what do you make of this trials so far
I'm not never a fan of her particularly
um and certainly during the hustings I
think she said some ridiculous things
um
so I I have my sort of doubts I thought
she came over all actually in pmqs today
that I thought she was more confident
more relaxed and less robotic I actually
thought she answered the questions we we
didn't get a sort of Cabaret as we were
from Boris Johnson I think she was
trying to be sort of straight talking
answer the questions and did appear more
confident really interesting to hear
your views I'll be interested to hear as
well as you know the kind of series goes
on whether they sort of shift or she
impresses you more or less and of course
after we get that news about energy
price announcement too thank you very
much indeed well let's bring in our
Deputy plus little editor Sam at Coates
at shall we were just talking in the
panel there a bit about Liz trans First
Impressions
um how do you feel uh she has gone I
guess in the first week
well talking to Tory MPS today they were
pleasantly surprised by her first outing
in prime minister's questions look it's
no secret as your panelists said that
there are some doubts that she can be a
little wooden she tried to turn that to
her favor during the leadership uh
contest suggesting that she wasn't as
slick as her opponent uh Rishi sunak
um but she doesn't have long to create
an impression for herself that's why
tomorrow is going to be absolutely key
with the energy announcement that
probably be the biggest spending
commitment she ever makes people will be
judging her on that because she's got an
uphill mountain to climb as I think
we're about to see here we can have a
look at some of the polling can't we and
it really is an uphill Mountain as you
as you say that's right and if we look
at this now what this is is a poll taken
just before the announcement of who was
going to be the conservative leader and
the next prime minister so this is as it
were the Baseline and look at that the
labor party lead the conservative party
by 15 percentage points that's a
whopping amount it's bigger than the
amount that Boris Johnson beat Jeremy
corbyn by in the 2019 general election
and almost as wearings he got really
quite good percentage figures there for
the liberal Democrat um who could eat
into seats particularly in the south of
England in fact 43 up here is the
highest amount in this Parliament for
labor 28 is the lowest amount in this
Parliament for the conservatives do we
go on to the next slide you can just see
the trend uh over time and that shows
you just how much uh has been going on
basically what happened as we'll see in
a second is you can be able to go on to
the next slide um is that roundabout
last October there was a switch and all
of a sudden you saw that and it was here
uh you saw that labor overtook the
conservatives now that was a point where
we started getting shortages
um price that the pump started going up
so it's real life experience that
actually informs people's voting
intentions rather than anything else and
then all the way through that bumpy
Autumn that translated into a really
turbulent political new year with the
party gate Affair and all of that labor
have maintained a sustained lead and
that has rocketed over the summer I
think the the disunity of the
conservative party really evident in the
last uh few weeks and I think all of
that means that Liz truss has an
enormous mountain to climb she of course
told the 1922 yesterday that the party
was on Election footing could it be
sooner than we think I wonder as well
with Liz trust like because I guess
there's two ways of looking at this and
what in the one how you look at this
post you think this is terrible as she's
got a crisis coming and the polling
shows that the conservative party is
unpopular compared to labor is there
perhaps an argument that the Baseline is
so low for whatever she does will be
seen as better than expected almost
certainly look the public when asked
what they think of her uh give her a
thumbs down on almost every subject by
about a margin of two to one she can
only outperform that and when she starts
spending and I think she is going to
spend a hell of a lot of money in the
coming days and weeks as Rishi sunak
found that might actually improve your
popularity now whether that's durable
and sustainable to the point where you
might actually reap rewards at The
Ballot Box we will see but it is worth
saying all the way along all the times
that we've talked about this there have
been problems with labor as well they
might be riding high in the polls but
they've still got issues with the over
65s where uh there's a majority of two
to one for the conservatives you've got
the SNP still strong in Scotland keeping
labor pushing labor down there and not
that many people switch directly from
the conservative party to labor Under
kirst Armor so lots of work for them to
do uh so I think Liz truss has every
reason to feel there's all to play for
interesting stuff would be really
critical few months ahead won't it Sam
thank you very much indeed
and now we have spent a lot of the show
understandably talking about the really
big domestic challenges facing the new
government but there's also no shortage
of issues to tackle on the world stage
not least of course the Ukraine war
which is driving the global energy
crisis as well as relations with the EU
the threat from China food shortages in
developing countries it is a long list
and we're joined now by the conservative
MP elysikens who sits on the Foreign
Affairs select committee thank you for
being with us
uh so Liz truss's first call was with
President zielinski of Ukraine you've
obviously done work with particularly
women in Ukraine as well and what are
you expecting to see from the new prime
minister in terms of that all-important
policy so I think we're going to see a
lot of focus on this kind of narrative
about threats and I think Ukraine and
Russia alongside obviously China where
she's Keen to show that she's going to
take a strong stance we're going to see
a lot of that I don't think we're going
to see any reduction support for Ukraine
I don't think we're going to see any
change but I would love to see as you
know she's announced this reconstruction
conference that she wants to do in 2023
that's the right plan we should always
be talking about reconstruction and
where we go forward but I think what we
really need to see is a fleshing out of
what does Putin must lose mean because
for months now we heard Boris say it we
heard Liz say it and I think we'll
continue to hear her say it but what
does that actually mean what does that
look like uh how much Authority and
autonomy are going to give to the
ukrainians to decide what Putin has lost
looks like
um so I think there's a lot of fleshing
out of that question that needs to be
done it feels to me like we're moving
into a new stage of the war almost
um
it feels unlikely that you know suddenly
Putin's going to take key but also feels
unlikely that he's suddenly is going to
withdraw it's almost like we're in a
cold war he he's using new tactics like
cutting off gas supply how do we react
to that so I think there's that really
murky bit of a war we get into that real
war attrition as we go into winter
everything will freeze
um and I have you know two Ukrainian
families living with me their hope is
that everything they will have success
by the time we get to Winter because
they know that everything freezes then
and that moment of freezing winter will
be a really interesting reset because we
will need to look around the world at
how much support we have and it's a real
vulnerability point so I think one of
the things I've been talking about is
this abstentionous countries who haven't
taken a view and haven't taken aside as
we go into winter when everything
freezes our countries who are currently
around who you're talking about also if
there's countries like India for example
uh there are countries a lot of the
commonwealth countries countries in
Latin America and so on so on a lot of
them haven't won State positions same in
the
indo-pacific
we already have them with their
positions but as we go into winter we
could see people who are currently with
us but going away and we need to make
sure we keep that support we maintain
that support and that's gonna be a real
challenge how much pressure do you put
on a country like India I mean we're
trying to sign a trade it with them as
well aren't we yeah I think that's an
enormous challenge I think the global
South this is what I think so Liz likes
to talk about her a network of Liberty
that again is something we need to flesh
outwards that mean what does it look
like is it operationalizing the
Commonwealth uh is it about looking at
these absentious countries she needs to
look at how we bring these people into
fold and how we make them work but these
countries don't want to be made to pick
and we have to be very careful it's the
same question when it comes to China you
cannot force these countries to pick and
actually their priority is uh in the
Pacific for example it's about surviving
climate change in the countries and
Global South it's about the famine
that's coming and the food shortages
um we can't just tell them they must
pick a side because we have particularly
we're not necessarily backing that up
with the support to allow them to make
that choice
um so it's a very sensitive diplomacy
and that's going to be the most biggest
challenge I think for this government is
the nuanced diplomacy you can't have
black and white relationships you can't
compartmentalize things when they're
unhelpful you have to have that
complicated discussion that's sometimes
quite tough and how do you think less
trust will approach that well look I
think Liz has shown that she's willing
to be a disrupter and she's achieved
some things as a result of doing that
and but she's also shown herself to be
someone who's listened so I went to her
last September and said I was really
worried about the walk-ins and in
particular Bosnia had a list of 13
things I would like to see her deliver
she live at 10 of 13 and the UK entire
policy towards Balkans and Bosnia
changed overnight we've been leading on
the world stage right so I think when
she can see there's a urgent need she
acts and she makes a difference and she
did that by bringing people together but
I also recognize that sometimes uh
playing to the crowds can lead to quite
a dangerous position in diplomacy there
are always cameras lights in action and
that can lead itself to those quick
quips that actually are quite dangerous
in the long run interesting you're
thinking about like macron for example
yeah and I think I think that was a not
very sensible move I don't think anyone
and disagree with that if she gave the
answer on China you could understand why
again you wouldn't want to tie yourself
either way but France is a major Ally we
need to work with them very closely
we've just come through the orcas
relationship difficulties
um and orcas was absolutely the right
decision that's gonna that is in the
long term one and being one of our key
defenses
are you worried that it and we're
talking here it does really properly
explained you know we're talking here
when she wasn't she refused to say
whether or not president Malcolm was an
ally could that damage our relationships
you think so I think it it obviously is
so important the relationship between
world two world leaders but actually we
see this so much in the media where oh
if this person this person don't become
best friends there can't be a positive
relationship between those countries but
the Frameworks and the Civil Service and
diplomatic relations those are actually
the fundamentals and they're not at risk
in any way gotta ask you are you going
to run for the now vacant position as a
chair of the Foreign Affairs select
committee so I've I'm really grateful
I've had a lot of positive conversations
with colleagues um over the last I guess
12 hours however long today yes I've
lost track of the day so I'm seriously
considering it and I think you know we
need someone who understands these
challenges knows what's under the Bonnet
and how the engine in the foreign Office
Works and I'm really touched by how many
people have reached out so uh I'm
definitely considering it sounds like a
yes
look it's my passion and I think I can
bring that experience of uh working
countering hostile States
counterterrorism and as I said
understand the foreign office and I
think hopefully colleagues have seen
that I'll work with them interesting
stuff Alyssa Cairns thank you very much
uh indeed for coming on the program
tonight well that is it for the take we
will be back next week and every week on
Wednesday at 9 00 PM next up you've got
Sky News at 10 thanks very much for
watching
see you next week
[Music]
foreign
Borneo I'm a sailor I spent half time of
my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
foreign
[Music]